das mag in new york eigentlich der
dritte habe ich aber den ersten und
zweiten block zusammengepackt also für
euch der zweite tag ich muss es glaube
ich gar nicht zu verklären
ich stehe hier gerade am central park an
einer bike station hier wird schon das
citybike blablabla da wollen wir uns
gleich auf jeden fall bike ausleihen und
mal ein bisschen lästig sein bepackt
waren war heute soll es ab 13 uhr
gewittern
allerdings wollen wir bis dahin noch ein
bisschen was erleben ist irgendwie 10
uhr oder so um den dreh und wir leiten
das ist mir so ein ding ausbeute des
bikes ausgeblieben fahren jetzt hier
durch den central park hier so sieht das
der geradeaus mit dem bike einfach
wunderschön aus also das wetter ist
jetzt noch gut ist soll wahrscheinlich
nachher noch so ein bisschen regnen und
gewittern wo wir das hier gerade aus ihr
hervor auch jetzt kaum leute von hinten
liegen müssen wir schon anders dass ich
auch wundervoll
hallo eine nette dame dahinter uns
gerade gesagt dass wir die ganze zeit
hier auf der autospur gefahren sind
deswegen wurden wir auch gerade
verhandlungen habe sowas erkennt man
erst mal gemacht dann also hier sollte
ich dass wir gerade aus es ist einfach
sehr sehr schön ist einfach so ein
riesiges großer spielplatz mitten in new
york und leben von hochhäusern einfach
klasse ich liebe diese stadt ist
erster zwischenstopp hier in so einem
kleinen see mitten im central park wir
senken unsere schweiz geparkt da stehen
die beiden süßen und tv also hier ist
wieder der central park
da vorne sind wir gerade hier runter
gekommen da hinten kann man dann auch
noch weiterfahren
aber wir bleiben jetzt erstmal hier ein
bisschen
ich hoffe euch gefällt übrigens alles
was ich bisher über diese kinder dahin
sofort gefällt ist ja was sich hier so
in new york filme und auch nicht dass
schneide und alles mögliche
ich bin auch derzeit natürlich bin ich
nicht mehr in new york weil ich dann
schon wieder zu hause bin und alles
geschnitten habe habe ich bin aufs netz
sehr aktiv und teile da immer was ich
mache also auch während der zeit als ich
in new york war habe ich sehr viel ins
netz gepackt das heißt ich werde
eventuell noch mal so ein video machen
wollte einfach meine ganze snap chat
stories aus dem tag über in new york
zusammen schneider aber sonst wenn ihr
wollt können mit erfolgen da ist sich
laser luca und sonst auch bei instagram
laser luca und da ist denke der ist
total.com randy gast dann überholt weil
solche rennfahrer
der ist gerade halt gemacht wenn ihr
euch jetzt mal sehen wie das hier gut
aussieht das ist einfach mega kratz
so wie sich alle seiten besteht einfach
so
wundervoll wirklich wieder einfach so
ein grüner fleck mitten im see mitten in
der riesigen stadt ist jetzt gerade im
central park irgendwo in der nähe wo
auch casey grund wir haben da vorne
stehen unsere bikes wir haben hier vorne
gerade eichhörnchen beobachtet und
werden jetzt uns irgendwie auf den
rückweg machen die bikes wieder abgeben
weil es soll wahrscheinlich in einer
stunde anfangen zu regnen und wir
wollten noch zu pink berry und
dann wären wir vielleicht national
history museum gehen kommentiert der
name national und wir sind jetzt auf
jeden fall durch den kompletten central
park durchgefahren hier haben wir haben
das hier gerade auf dem touring handy
aufgerufen da ist die center parcs
gewünschten die eine blaue linie
abgefahren und werden dann
wahrscheinlich hier hinten dann wiederum
zurückfahren
auf kleiner zwischenfall die kette ist
ab war klar dass wir sowas dann scheint
eine halbe stunde bevor wir das ding
abgeben müssen ist scheiße
zudem entsprachen so carina abgegeben
werden jetzt so wars mitfahren weil wir
das unbedingt mal sehen möchten
da wenig sinn wenn wir da noch was
fressen und danach wollten wir in
national history museum of american
history museum national blabla
wir sind jetzt gerade in der branche
angekommen sieht einfach richtig hammer
aus man sieht sogar dahin wenn man da
zwischendurch schaut da hinten sieht man
noch weitere wolkenkratzer das ist
einfach so crazy jetzt auch die new
yorker stock exchange wo an der börse
gehandelt wird mit wertpapieren lenkt
sich zwar einfach man fährt 40 minuten
konstant fahren oder 20 aber ich halt
einfach so
doch überall hochhäuser es ist einfach
immer noch alles so wie sich das ist
einfach unfassbar als wenn diese stadt
gar kein ende hat
jetzt gerade kombis oder sondern diese
margarita broich die ist ich zeig euch
mal meine hand die es so klein und wir
haben acht dollar deshalb oder so aber
mal schauen wie die mäcklers schon
probiert wie würdest du die bewährten
bisher auf einer skala von 2 bis 27 15
also denkt wahrscheinlich mag auf jeden
fall okay natürlich
herford richtig gesehen ich habe mich
wieder eine pizza geholt war echt planen
und davon bin ich nicht geworden
deswegen hab ich mir noch eine holt man
dies auch recht günstig dass das jetzt
drei dollar seinen fleiß oder so das ist
schon irgendwie recht groß wer mit
bedacht spontan eventuell zum zu
falscher zu fahren
mit einer fähre sind es auch die fähre
gekommen die kosten und fahren dahin
dahin müssen irgendwo die aber immer
etwas der bildung da hinten ist die
freiheitsstatue und so der warenwert
schön hin
roland flade einer statue wir dachten
eigentlich dass das brot uns dahin führt
allerdings sind wir unseren vorbei
gefahren und das wird jetzt aber ein
bisschen besser wenn haben wir uns das
gedacht dass sie im duell zum wohl
schneller gehen
von daher ist der mittelpunkt in new
york oder der
der höhere preis deckeln und hin
verändert werden wir dann eventuell
hochgeht eventuell noch nicht erlebt
hätte den nächsten videos leben
permanent dazu entschlossen aufs world
trade center zu gehen weil das wetter
einfach richtig schön geworden des
services gewinnt das ist die so einen
flughafen eigentlich als müssen gerade
banken abheben und ein mal sondern
und so sieht das jetzt gerade aus also
ich war noch nie auf so ein hochwasser
schützen was ich bisher war es glaube
ich das land in eine ganz neue erfahrung
für mich
nein also die waren gerade da vorne
irgendwo ich weiß ja ganz froh ist das
ist schon krass einfach wenn man sich
mal überlegt was damals passiert ist
aber jetzt gibt's halt one world trade
center und der ausblick ist einfach viel
krasser und machen ich bin einfach höher
als das da hinten und auch dahinter ist
immer noch das rockefeller center höher
ist das sind wir auch das ist so krass
und es ist halt echt so als wir drin war
nach der gewinn das wetter war in
ordnung jetzt integrierte draußen und
jetzt kommen schon die ersten
regentropfen runter aber es ist halt
trotzdem kasse waren gerade in diesem
riesigen gebäude da drin da vorne sieht
man nur noch den regen da oben aber das
ist einfach eine erfahrung fürs reden
und ich kann die mannschaft nicht
als mit jedem moment die welt untergehen
bin froh dass wir nicht nach dem world
meine komplette
wegen streitigkeiten zwischen dem vor
dafür dort nicht mehr auf dem world
trade center
weil megabit mega stürmisch ich zeige
ich dass man sich beispielsweise hierhin
filme oder beispielsweise auch das
memorial denkmal hier weiß nicht ob man
das hört oder sieht aber es ist heftig
am regnen und da oben wäre das ganze
ding jetzt einfach voll krass am wackeln
und man bestellt einfach vom platz
man bekommt eine karte
kurz das haus und dann wieder hinten auf
einen zug das ist einfach
total krass was sagst du zu dem
burgerking karten soll das ist ganz
schön innovativ aufgehört zu regnen und
wird
ich hasse das ist finde so ein haar
einfach mutter heckte das sind die
voller gehöre dass so etwa das packt so
ab wir haben uns gerade darum gefragt
wie zur wall street kommen und da laufen
wir jetzt hin weil da wollten jetzt noch
in die kirche der dreifaltigkeit gehen
und weil das wetter einfach nicht mehr
so neuen konzepten wie eventuell gedacht
zum ruckeln bridge aber das alles weil
das wetter nicht so alt ist ja vor der
wir wahrscheinlich gerade gesehen haben
konnten wir leider nicht return
jeweiligen geschlossen war oder so
deswegen haben uns jetzt dazu
entschlossen einfach das wird auch noch
ein bisschen besser geworden ist dass es
heute irgendwie so weg klappt dass wir
zur brooklyn bridge ein und gehen ich
weiß nicht ob man sehen kann doch das
kann man nicht ganz gesehen dahin ist
die brooklyn bridge und die geht halt
hier so rüber und da werden wir uns dann
gleich drauf stellt und mal schauen was
man von da so alles sehen kann von einer
linse
wir sind angekommen auf der brooklyn
bridge wird nicht du dich keiner
vermisst dich mal da ist die skyline
hier bin ich gelaufen jetzt brachte über
und arbeite wie zb putin bei instagram
anschauen können oder sich einfach
wirklich wundervoll aus dieser stadt ist
ein reinster traum das hat die komplette
skyline
da ist das meer hier ist die andere
seite von der brooklyn bridge
hier ist der ganze verkehr da sie über
leute da ist die sönke soll ich mal so
freunde wir sind jetzt raus aus der u
bahn station laufen jetzt zurück zum
hotel und sind wahrscheinlich so in zwei
minuten fußweg sind die ca dann war's
das auch schon für den heutigen blog
also wir haben relativ viel eigentlich
noch erlebt dafür dass eigentlich das
wetter relativ schaffen sein sollte das
heißt da bin ich ganz froh auf uns es
ist doch so dass meine fühlt man ich
fühle mich richtig so als hätte ich hier
leben meine füße auch so die schule so
ein bisschen und so waren einst hat day
auf jeden fall kann ich sagen es euch
gefallen ob ich mich über den daumen
hoch freue ich mich wieder der akku ist
am limit und dann dem wir uns im
nächsten video wieder und ich hoffe der
akku werde jetzt gleich nicht